I'm James Williams with Discovery News,...
...this is Uncle Sam,...
...and this is James Heintze, Librarian Emeritus at American University in Washington, DC,...
...and he's gonna give us the story on the real Uncle Sam.
Uncle Sam is one of the most interesting and popular American icons...
...whose origin lies in a meat - packing plant in Troy, New York.
In 1812, a government inspector with the name of Elbert Anderson...
...was purchasing meat from this factory...
...whose manager was Sam Wilson.
When they packed the meat in their oak barrels,...
...they stamped the barrels E . A . for the name Elbert Anderson and U . S . as United States government stores.
But a number of workers in the factory got together and decided to, as a joke,...
...refer to the U . S . as Uncle Sam.
That joke spread throughout the entire factory...
...and also throughout the town of Troy, New York.
And eventually, throughout New England.
As early as the late 1820s,...
...individuals were referring to the US government already as Uncle Sam.
In the 1830s, people were asking the question throughout New England,...
"What did Sam Wilson actually look like?"
And the caricaturist depicted him as a rather tall man with a thin stature.
And that seemed to catch on. Perhaps he really was very tall and thin.
But that character would continue on throughout the 19th century.
Happy birthday United States and happy birthday Uncle Sam.